what about the other candidate that uh
according to the subreddit and as you
mentioned you've criticized it a little
bit uh Marianne Williamson do you think
what are the pros and cons of horizon
candidate
this is another area where many in my
audience really are angry with me yeah I
don't find her candidacy super
interesting I'll tell you the pros and
the cons as I see them I do think that
we have elected officials in the U.S
particularly presidents from a really
narrow range of backgrounds so it's
lawyers and sometimes business people
very very often lawyers I would I think
we would benefit from a much greater
diversity of backgrounds and I once said
and that would include uh people from
education people from the Science World
people with backgrounds maybe running
non-profits Etc now Marianne Williamson
did I guess at one point run some kind
of small non-profit and some in my
audience thought that credential alone
would make me fall head over heels in
love with the idea of a Marianne
candidacy I've interviewed for her it's
just not for me is the way I like to say
it it's the the background of the
woo-woo type stuff is a bit off-putting
to me I understand that someone with
literal Christian Bible beliefs that
also I I don't like maybe I'm more
willing to accept as most of our
presidents of course have had those
views because they're otherwise more
qualified but some of the things that
she says just strike me as I just I just
don't know I'll give you an example
when she was on with Russell Brand she
said there's no such thing as clinical
depression it just means someone in a
clinic told you you have depression
I don't believe that to be the case I
think we have an understanding there's
two types of depression there's like a
genetic predisposition depression
there's like a acute something's
happening in my life temporary
depression okay you know when she was
asked about it recently she said
I didn't mean it I was just trying to
impress Russell Brand
I don't know if I'm more bothered by the
things she first said or that by the
fact that she wanted to impress Russell
Brand but it's just like it's just
really not for me and I agree with her
on we need to take the climate more
seriously we need to expand access to
hell I I'm with all of that stuff now I
want to say one other thing about this
anybody who wants to run should run I am
not suggesting there should be an
uncontested primary for Joe Biden
absolutely so you think it should be
contested well what I mean by contested
is so there's two parts to what we mean
by contested will the DNC organize
debates and we'll get to that in a
second but should should anybody who's
on the left get out of the way because
Joe Biden is President and he's running
for re-election absolutely not the
question about should there be debates I
would like there to be debates the DNC
pretty clearly isn't going to organize
them I think if you did them you would
have to say at what polling level do you
qualify
and I don't know exactly where you put
that number but I think it would be a
great thing to put Joe Biden on a stage
with if you can get what six percent
eight percent I'm not really sure what
the number would be I'm totally all for
that